well this was police trying to
infiltrate activists groups
um by going undercover and becoming
personal friends and sometimes getting
into sexual relationships with activists
and what the reporters found is that it
was unjustified that if the public had
known about it it would have been
brought to a rapid end it says that the
Commissioners the police had our senior
officers to look into the activities of
these doctors and and they had found in
1976 in a report that they brought out
that it was useful it was providing good
information but what the report author
says in in this report is that what they
didn't really look into in enough detail
was the methods that were being used
such as using the names of dead babies
in order to infiltrate the group to
having sexual activities with some of
these women in some cases fathering
children with people who they were
spying on and what it says is that if
that was known at home this level it
should have been shut down I think what
the activists might find disappointing
in this is it is only an interim report
this has been going on for a long time
this inquiry was launched in 2015 by
Theresa May and so far it's only saying
um it's not really going into the detail
of what it's going to say about the the
sexual activities and the reports of the
police and and and how those uh
relationships were entered into and it
doesn't actually say at this point who
is the most senior person who knew the
detail of what was going on it does
suggest that that they knew that these
undercover activities were taking place
but it doesn't say you know at the
highest level did the Home Secretary for
example know the extent of what was
going on did the commissioner know those
those those names of who knew at the
highest level haven't come out yet